هذا الاستهداف تم
بمقاتلي اسرائيليه كيف تبدو المعطيات
الميدانيه لعمليه الاستهداف
والاغتيال نعم سلمى بالفعل مازلنا في هذا
المكان في منطقه المشرفيه هنا هذا هو مكتب
حركه حماس الذي تم استهدافه في هذا
الانفجار باكثر من صاروخ من مسيره
اسرائيليه منذ اكثر من اربع ساعات سلمى
وما زالت الاجهزه الامنيه في هذا المكان
تجري مسحا دقيقا جدا لادق التفاصيل التي
يمكن العثور عليها في الشقه المستهدفه
وكذلك في محيط هذا المبنى مازالت فرق
الدفاع المدني ايضا موجوده في هذا المكان
لمواكبه كل عمليات المسح والاخلاء وهناك
يعني مسح دقيق جدا كما لاحظنا من قبل
العناصر الامنيه
والاجهزه المختصه فالمكان له رمزيه كبيره
سياسيا وامنيا ايضا هنا في عمق الضاحيه
الجنوبيه لبيروت في منطقه المشرفيه هذا
المكان الذي هو كما هو معروف معقل لحزب
الله هذا ما يتطلب ربما ب بعدا اعمق واكثر
دقه للتحقيقات التي تجري في
هذه العمليه عمليه اغتيال فتحت بعض
الطرقات المؤديه الى هذا المكان منذ بعض
الوقت ولكن ما زالت ما زال هناك طوق امني
شديد ومكثف من قبل العناصر الامنيه
اللبنانيه في محيط موقع
الانفجار طبعا منطقه المشرفيه في عمق
الضاحيه الجنوبيه لها رمزيه كبيره سبق
لضاحي بيروت الجنوبيه ان تعرضت لهجوم
بمسيرات في مرات سابقه منذ سنوات سلمى
وايضا في مرات عديده كان الطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي يحلق بكثافه في اجواء بيروت
وايضا فوق منطقه الضاحيه لذلك هناك اليوم
الكثير من التساؤلات حول ال ابعاد هذا
الاغتيال وما يمكن ان تكون تداعياته على
اكثر من مستوى كما كان قد ذكر الزميل مازن
ابراهيم اذا هذا هو الوضع حتى هذه اللحظه
حماس نعت سبعه من قيادييها وهناك بحسب
المصادر الطبيه اللبنانيه نحو عشره جرحى
ايضا سقطوا واصيبوا في هذا الانفجار ما
زالت الشقه كما تبدو في هذه اثناء وهناك
كما يبدو في الصوره عدد من عناصر الاجهزه
الامنيه ما زالت ايضا تواكب كل ا كل ما
جرى وتبحث عما يمكن ان يشكل دليلا يساعد
في التحقيقات التي انطلقت في هذا الانفجار
سلمى